[Music]
[Applause]
Brent mossberger Hall of Famer and uh
he's got a pre-game anchor gig oh he's
back back the countdown to kickoff with
Brent Musburger and uh every Sunday from
noon till one Eastern on Vision the
sports betting Network he joins us now
Hi Brent how are you
I'm good I'm good Dan how you been my
good but look you're you selling all
that stuff that's in front of you there
at the desk is that what you're doing
now no no no those are just uh
tchotchkes I I collect did you collect
all the years that you covered Sports
any interesting memorabilia
yeah if you go up into a storage bin up
in Montana you can find things like
Catholics versus the convicts uh that
was 88 uh a young Notre Dame student I
think he got kicked out of school for it
Dan but it was a big big time meeting
Jimmy Johnson was coaching the canes Lou
Holtz was coaching a fighting Irish and
uh it was a meeting for the number one
ranking in the country and this young
man had these t-shirts printed and he
gave it to me it just broke me up before
the game now I had taped an opening to
that game but I had to redo it because
uh the Keynes and the Irish got into a
fist fight after they left and they
changed how they came on the field after
that so you know things like that a lot
lots of great memories there's a few oh
by the way
I do have from the 50s a Mickey Mantle
baseball card the tops it's not it's not
an A1 condition but it's in pretty good
condition I have almost the entire first
set of Topps baseball cards my my mother
did not throw them out they were in the
basement okay so I found them what do
you think that's worth
well
what the last one sell for Dan it went
for a good dollar I know that a few
million right
yeah yeah like I said it's you know the
uh the ones that are ranked at 10
they're centered directly on the card
this one of Mickey is over just a little
bit so that the border is not perfect on
both sides so that would uh that would
hurt the uh the value of it a little bit
because I know what they're looking for
so it's not I wouldn't rank it at 10. I
might rank it up seven and a half
something like that yeah do you still
have your CBS Blazer when you guys did
the NFL today
oh yeah I've got it somewhere tucked
away uh sure you know they didn't you
you know the logo that now that they all
wear and they've worn for years we
didn't have that uh back in the day okay
okay I think
maybe NBC
might have started the Blazers first I
no probably ABC now that I think of ruin
our age probably uh started the Blazers
ahead how much competition was there
back in the day when when CBS did their
pregame show in NBC with Bryant Gumbel
did There's how how competitive were you
two
there's really I mean I you know we
battled for battle for viewers every
week uh
both of us very competitive and uh you
know we've been friends for the years uh
it wasn't certainly wasn't personal but
um the big thing about the NFL today
damn back in that day was the fact
that the NFC East
in the Chicago Bears and the then Los
Angeles Rams before they moved to St
Louis
they were all good teams so we had the
major markets we we dominated then
because of the NFC things have flipped
obviously and they flipped depending on
the quarterbacks that you're having uh
in each given conference but the Dallas
Cowboys the New York Giants then the
Washington Redskins George Allen was
down there I mean great great games uh
Dick Vermeil took over the Philadelphia
Eagles and made them relevant uh you had
to run into the Bears in the mid 80s
with Refrigerator Perry in there Jim
McMahon Walter Payton and all that so so
we dominated during that time but it
wasn't so much us or the pregame as it
was at games we were leading into it's
kind of an interesting story at CBS
um a lot of people are real 60 Minutes
had failed midweek and they sort of
shoved it into Sunday uh just to have a
place for it but it was the NFL
especially especially the Dallas Cowboys
that turned that program around we were
under orders to get out as quickly as we
could with the second game of the
doubleheader and we had a producer by
the name of Chuck Milton who always did
the key game
and if you go back and look at the time
frames he would always run it a little
past seven o'clock in the East and
coming up next on CBS 60 minutes we
dumped huge audiences into the show and
they took it from there Mike Wallace and
again he took it from there and so I
always said the NFLs are what made UH 60
Minutes
um must must View television back in the
day and of course you gotta remember we
only had the major networks back in the
day
um NPR was in was in we didn't have any
cable I mean ESPN was born while the NFL
today was uh was up on the air and so
you know we had more of an exclusivity
back in the day but it was it was great
it was great and I couldn't help but
think of Pat Summerall with Angela
Lansbury dying you know with the show
murder
She Wrote
and the fact that he would do it and and
extend that pause because there's a
comma and it felt like he he wanted to
do that to crack up John Mann but he
would be and coming up murder
she wrote and Madden got the biggest
kick out of that when Pat would do that
yeah you know that's an interesting
story too because we had a big
production meeting uh Vanguard and
solder was in the head of uh head of CBS
Sports and there was actually a debate
that as to who John Madden was going to
work with now there is an outer who
never gets any credit long forgotten
but Madness first partner was Gary
Bender
and and Gary Bender was one of the most
generous announcers of all time NBA
announcer too yeah he really taught John
how to handle a booth and the monitors
and everything and then it became the
debate was between Pat Summerall or
Vince Scully okay and and about yeah
half of the people in that meeting
including van were pushing for Scully to
be Madden's partner but what won out was
the feeling and it was accurate that
with Summerall Madden would have more
room that uh Pat was more succinct uh
whereas Vinnie with his eloquent way
would occupy more of the broadcast time
I I think that was correct I think it
was a it was a win-win someone had been
working with Tom Brookshire and uh they
were fun together
obviously Brookie was was more of a
character and then John came along and
uh and it was a perfect pairing and
scully's scully's last game for CBF Dan
was with um
Hank Strahan was the analyst and it was
Dwight Clark with the touchdown catch
that beat the Cowboys in the playoffs in
uh in San Francisco that was scully's
last football call for CBS so he went
out with a he went out with a great game
and we're talking to Brent Musburger you
have these characters like Dick Vitale
you wouldn't think that would be
somebody who would be Transcendent that
he would last for decades uh even Chris
Berman John Madden it's how do you
explain these certain characters where
you wouldn't put them in and go yeah
right out of Central Casting they work
why do they work
they're genuine
um they're different
uh they're loud
you cannot ignore them as they um as
they go forward uh what was it the
fastest three minutes in the NFL tonight
I was listening and I said there's my
buddy and Chris is still grinding it
away Howard coach cell
uh another one of those characters but I
think that the most important thing
about all of them they're genuine all
right did you know coach sell that well
oh I know him oh
yeah I I really knew Howard
um
he was he was a character he became
insufferable later okay to tell you the
truth if you were on one side of the
street I mean Manhattan and you saw you
stay on the other side
but at his Peak okay people have
realized that he started in broadcasting
he was little league baseball coach and
they were just looking for somebody to a
radio show and and Howard did it but um
I'll never forget
Kurt Gowdy the old cowboy he and he and
Howard were uh were out drinking and uh
Gotti was another good friend he told me
the story and
one thing led to another and uh suddenly
it was done and in Manhattan and and
Howard had to do his uh radio show come
with me Cowboy I'll show you how you do
a radio show
Howard's condo complex an update going
to the elevator Kurt said and there was
a New York Times back in the day they
delivered newspapers you know they put
them right outside the door and there
was the New York Times and uh Howard
grabbed it went in went into the condo
and it was a closet this could sit right
right there to the left and
to open the door and rummaging through
shoes and everything and he pulled the
microphone out and there was a telephone
there and a connection with the studio
this is Howard Cosell speaking of sport
yeah the New York Times there I think
the NBA season was probably on and he
went through the New York Knicks in a
game that night and everything and
this is Howard Cosell signing off until
tomorrow he slams it down shows over and
he said at Cowboy that cowboy that is
how you do reading
daddy said it just it broke him up
forever more
um because that was an unbelievable
Talent
um and he could do it right to the
second
ad-lib and and then ended and he loved
putting on a show I had my wife Arlene
we were to well actually roon was trying
to hire me at ABC so we went to a Monday
night game at uh
down in Miami a little Orange Bowl
and Howard came in and he had not met
Arlene so he gets into a conversation
and uh you know he's putting me down and
he's talking to Arlene he's going and
the stage manager is yelling at Howard
Howard we're on the air on 30 seconds
you know and so on and he walks and
opens up uh he was a genius and um
it it you know
the first night uh Pete Roselle told me
that
um at least a half dozen owners after
that opening Monday night game between
the Jets and the Cleveland Browns on ABC
at least a half dozen called The League
office and demanded that Roselle get rid
of Cosell from the broadcast wow and so
Roselle
told me he he called roon Arledge to
have a conversation with him and he said
it was rude or convinced him under no
circumstance would he change
uh Howard was there to stay and
Pete your job is to tell the owners
and Pete sided with with Rood in that
and went back to the owners and said we
think he's going to be good for us and
and the rest is history I mean Howard
brought in record audiences he was the
first one you know the halftime
highlights were really relevant back in
the day because you didn't see every
game and you were thrilled if he did
your team you know oh yeah well you you
got upset if he didn't yeah people were
upset with Howard
the uh countdown to kick off with Brent
Musburger so each Sunday from noon until
one Eastern so uh what's special about
this show that you're gonna do
well you know what's interesting is
because Dan and you and I have talked
about the legalization of gambling
across the country and vsan actually
proceeded the Supreme Court ruling which
opened it up and now uh we've got
upwards of 40 states where it's going to
be like I think Ohio legalizes the first
year I think somebody told me about it
anyway uh it's an enormous party all you
have to do is watch an NFL game now and
and you see the ads from DraftKings in
particular they have DraftKings of
course bought vsen so in effect we work
for DraftKings now and you can see the
amount of advertising they do up on the
game so but
in that last hour in the countdown to
kickoff on vcent the last hour before
they kick it off millions and millions
of dollars uh changed hands in the
legalized betting markets so those
numbers those numbers are changing and
you know we we come up with relevant
statistics for example in the first part
of the Season that people like to bet
over unders you know they preferred
about the over that's a little bit more
fun but in divisional games the unders
hit at a dramatic rate I mean it was it
was make money time if if you were a
better who followed things like that so
we do that
there's also always a couple of injuries
always a couple of injuries that you've
got to keep an eye on and then just like
we did with the NFL today there's
weather we had wind in a couple of
places and and you know wind is more
important than actually rain snow things
like that because it affects a passing
game uh when you go into that win so
those are the things that are relevant
and we talk to people uh Michael Gunn
runs at South Point we get the updated
odds down there Derek Stevens opened up
this unbelievable sports book here at
Circa at the other end of town so so we
talked to their people and their
bookmakers and and try to pass along
relevant information I don't listen I
and I've said this to you many many
times the youngsters in particular be
careful if you think you're coming in
and you're going to regularly beat these
numbers forget about it it's not going
to happen Okay but if you want to have a
little fun you got a little extra cash
to put out there on a ball game go ahead
go ahead and go for it but don't think
that you're going to make your living
betting the National Football League I
mean these bookies these numbers are
very very tough I'll leave you with this
how warm is the seat for Josh McDaniels
in Vegas
well warmer than anybody expected okay
uh one in four
and there were some questionable
decision I had been to one game I went I
went in person and watched the Denver
game okay and I thought he handled the
sideline very very well I have good
seats that I could watch down below and
I thought it was a very good performance
that's the game that won but a study
made some strange decisions on on Monday
night now I don't mind anybody going for
two especially when you're on the road
to take the lead but when I see four
minutes and 30 seconds up there I'm not
sure what you gain even if you're one
point ahead you've given
arguably one of the two best
quarterbacks in the league Patrick
Mahomes an awful lot of time to get down
there and score again and regain the
lead now if you're down if you're down
to a minute minute 30 and you've scored
that touchdown and you're on the road
and you're an underdog go for it and
then he came down the field late he got
the ball back and it was unfortunate
that Devonte Adams didn't get the second
foot down but then Dan they had a
fourth and very very short and he had
already gambled once going along for a
touchdown in the first quarter and he
threw it deep again and I thought wait a
minute you know Josh Jacobs when I'm
missing something Jacobs is having a
really good night and they had run a
play against Denver where they lined
Jacobs up as a fullback and brought in a
different running back at the tail and
the defensive line obviously thinks that
Jacobs is coming straight ahead and then
they pitched to the rookie from Georgia
white and he ran for an easy first down
I I just thought it was strange now I
now now having said that the game that I
watched in person I was impressed uh the
offensive line coach it's not they're
not good talent wives across the line
but the offensive line coach is doing a
good job okay he he mixes and matches
and he uses his rookie uh more in the
second half than he does in the first he
does good a defense defense needs needs
a lot of work this is not a uh
this is not a contender for the Super
Bowl uh the schedule gets a little bit
easier after this week which is a bye
week they could climb back into a chance
to get into the playoffs
but um Mark Davis is very impatient uh
he inherited that from his father but
and I know after they went oh and three
they had a long meeting kept him from
the press and that so I
I don't know as far as a fan base is
concerned uh you know they're willing to
give him some time Dan I I think but but
I must say Monday night I thought there
was some strange decisions
good luck with the show it's always
great to talk to you uh keep in touch
thank you Brent right keep that
collection going that's uh Brent
Musburger Hall of Famer and uh the
sports betting Network announcing
countdown to kickoff with Brent
Musburger that'll be every Sunday from
noon until one Eastern